hey guys so Norton just launched an
industry-leading AI powered scam
detection tool and brand new innovation
from Norton called Norton Genie thank
you to Norton for sponsoring this video
let's check it out now while scam is
getting more and more sophisticated it
is getting harder to figure out what's
real and what's fake and with the rise
of artificial intelligence scammers can
create thousands of Fake Messages almost
instantly so Norton is fighting fire
with fire by creating a breakthrough
tool that uses AI to help people detect
scams via texts emails social media and
it continues to learn as more inputs are
added to the app now when you download
it it'll take you through the entire
setup process it's super simple and you
can get started right away it's free now
if you don't have any scams at the
moment you can test it out using their
sample setup here it'll show you the
entire process so you'll be ready the
next time you get a scam text or email
it is so awesome that Norton is making
all of these Cool Tools to keep us ahead
of these scams do you think that you can
outsmart the scammers download the app
and tell me what you think